راحه بقى البيان الختامي لقمه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي بانعقاد القمه الخليجيه
الصينيه والقمه العربيه الصينيه في الرياض
وعربه عن تطلع الدول الاعضاء لان تسهم
القمه الخليجيه الصينيه والقمه العربيه
الصينيه في تعزيز التعاون والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع الصين وعقد البيان دعم
المجلس الاعلى لمجلس التعاون للخليجي
لقرارات مجموعه اوبك بلس لتحقيق التوازن
في اسواق النفط كما شذى المجلس الاعلى في
نتائج القمه الخليجيه الامريكيه في اطار
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه واشدد البيان على
قوه وتماسك مجلس التعاون واكد ان دول
المجلس كل لا يتجزا وفقا لمبدا الدفاع
المشترك ومفهوم الامن الجماعي
الذي استهدف منطقه تقسيم وسط مدينه
اسطنبول التركيه اخيرا كما ادانا البيان
ما سماه استمرار ايران في دعم الجماعات
الارها هو الميليشيات الطائفيه كما دعا
البيان الختابي العراق الى استكمال ترسيم
الحدود البحريه مع الكويت بعد العلامه 126
بعربا عن رفضه القاطع لاي انتهاك يمس
السياده الكويتيه
واختفاظها بحقها في الرد وفق القنوات
القانونيه